[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: My guest today
is Joe Born from the start
up responsible for the
Hale Dreamer device
that we have here on the table.
Welcome to the show, Joe.
JOE BORN: Thanks for having me.
MARTIN OMANDER: Could you tell
us a bit about your startup?
JOE BORN: Yeah.
So we started up-- we're
a hardware manufacturer
and we started up
with the mission
to provide accessories--
particularly,
audio accessories-- for the
underserved Android segment.
So first speaker dock
with a remote control.
We released the Hale
Dreamer you see here.
So first nightstand dock
with the silence feature
and the snooze bar.
And we recently became
[? Iowa ?] [? USA ?] so lots
of announcements
coming up on that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, great.
Congratulations.
So this is hardware.
I can touch this as opposed to
most of the startups-- well,
certainly, all the
startups I worked on
and most of the
startups I interview
here are software-only plays.
Hardware is hard, I've heard.
Why do you do it?
JOE BORN: Well, two reasons.
One, obviously, sometimes
you need a sensor.
We needed something to charge
the phone, you need a speaker,
sometimes you need a pedometer,
whatever it might be.
Less obvious is
the fact that there
are very well-established,
mature sales
channels that really do help
you create awareness and sell
your product.
So all the brick
and mortar that's
established and the
online channels.
So you may say, geez,
if Fry's or wherever
is very daunting with the
amount of products on there,
but it's nothing compared
to the Google Play Store,
for example, which the
shelves would be endless
if you had a physical
manifestation.
So it does help you to create
awareness and sell products.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I see.
Yeah.
Because I've seen
this product on store
shelves here in California.
And as you say, there are
far fewer products on there.
How do you become one of those
relatively few products who
get shelf space?
JOE BORN: Well, this has
changed a lot over my career.
And the good news is for the
people watching your show
is that it starts
online and it starts
in a very self-service
environment.
So all the major--
virtually, most
of the major brick
and mortars have
online, self-service areas.
So Best Buy and Walmart and
Sears and most notably, Amazon
where you list the
product yourself
very similar to
putting it on the Play
Store with the description.
And then you get in the flow
of Amazon and all the search
results so that now
people looking on Amazon
will see your product side
by side with all the others.
And it's the reviews
or the sales history
that are all driven analytically
and allow you to rise up.
And that's the first stage.
All the major brick-and-mortar
retailers, small and big,
look at those reviews and
look at that sales history,
and that gets you your start.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
so the reviews--
I've seen the reviews
for your product online.
They're really good.
So the brick-and-mortar
guys, they look at that?
JOE BORN: Absolutely.
All of them.
From the small early adopters
to the big national chains,
all look at how you're
doing and how well
your product is
received on Amazon.
It just make sense.
They want to know if it's
well liked on Amazon,
it's more than likely going
to be well liked at Costco,
or Fry's, or Best
Buy or wherever.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Right.
Yeah.
So I could see if you're Samsung
or a big, established hardware
manufacturer like
that, it's very easy
to get into those meetings
with Fry's Electronics
and the other
brick-and-mortar guys.
How do you as a
relatively unknown startup
get those meetings?
JOE BORN: Yeah.
Well, it can be a challenge.
Certainly, you are an unknown
startup, like you say.
You've got a smaller line than
the big, established players,
but there's good news here too.
One is that there are early
adopter channels for this.
So Fry's, Micro Center, and
the like pride themselves
on being very cutting edge
and having everything that's
available an early
adopter would want.
And two, again, all
of them are looking
towards reviews
and sales history.
So there certainly
are national chains
that even reached out
to really successful,
early Amazon products.
And regardless of whether
they reach out to you
or you reach out to them,
it really does matter.
And you're not at
all starting cold.
Secondly, these sales channels
are more open than, I think,
most your audience
might imagine.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
JOE BORN: Yeah.
Well, you can hire
manufacturers reps, for example,
that work in a territory, that
have those relationships, that
have the expertise, and they
work solely on commission.
So now you've piggybacked
on somebody else that
knows this space and that
gets you the meetings
and allows you to get
up to speed much sooner
than if you're doing
it by yourself.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
so you were using reps
like this on commission?
JOE BORN: Yeah.
So we use regional reps
that have relationships
and expertise in
any given territory
and they bring you in
and get the meetings
and help to advise you as to
what's working and what's not,
and what the buyers
are thinking,
and what direction they're
going, things like that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, I see.
So do they handle
the meetings or are
you also in those meetings?
How does that work?
JOE BORN: Both.
We always attend the
meetings because you're
talking about buyers
who have a lot of domain
knowledge in these areas
and these categories.
There is such a rich
volume of information.
This is what's working.
This is what we have
found problematic.
This is pricing that we found
to work and things like that.
So in a world where
everything is so data-driven,
we forget that human expertise
still does have a great value.
And those meetings to
us are terrifically
rich in figuring out
what we should do
and getting a reaction
from those buyers
as to what has been a
good area, and what's
been a good approach, and
how to sell those products.
A whole host of
details from packaging
to presentation in retail.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, so
it's not just matter
of you trying to convince
them to, hey, sell our stuff.
It is you're getting
valuable feedback from them.
JOE BORN: Oh, absolutely.
You want to take their feedback.
You want to take your sales
history at smaller channels--
take your Fry's, your
Micro Center, of course,
Amazon-- learn from
that and iterate.
The last thing you want to
do is launch too quickly
in a giant national
retailer to find out
that you have a
product problem or you
have a presentation problem or
something about your packaging
isn't clear.
Very hard to make
changes on the fly
if you're already in thousands
of outlets with huge inventory
investments, you
really can be stuck.
So it's best to do it in phases
where you go from one step
to another.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So do you sell more
of these online
or in brick-and-mortar
stores today, Joe?
JOE BORN: So today, we're
really just still getting
out to brick and mortars
so we sell more online.
That's fairly typical.
You start online.
You start with these
early adopter accounts.
And then you grow to national
retailer at which point,
the national retailer tends
to dwarf the sales of online.
Now for the first
time, Amazon actually
outsold Walmart on electronics.
First time last year.
But you've got to
remember, Amazon
has probably 100
times more products.
So for any given
product that you
get on the shelves at
a national retailer,
you're probably
selling a lot more
than you were on Amazon,
generally speaking.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, I see.
So you're seeing it as a
three-stage process then?
Online pioneering, offline,
and then mainstream offline?
JOE BORN: Yeah.
That's generally a good way
to think of it with the two
clustered.
So your Amazon, your Newegg, and
Fry's, and Micro Center, those
can be pretty early on.
You're talking about
some dozens of stores,
so it's easy to manage that
inventory and that feedback,
customer service,
all that stuff.
You get to the
national retailer,
that's a whole
different category.
Thousands of stores,
huge amounts of inventory
and product moving
through the channel.
So you really need to
have your act together
by the time you
get on that stage.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh,
the major leagues.
JOE BORN: The major
leagues, so to speak.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Well, best of luck in
the major leagues, Joe.
And thank you very much for
coming on the show today.
JOE BORN: Yeah.
Thanks for having me.
MARTIN OMANDER: We hope
you found something
you can use in your startup.
Your input matters.
Please leave your
comments below.
We read all of them.
To learn how Google
can help your startup,
go to
developers.google.com/startups.
If you would like
to be on the show,
go to bit.ly/applyrootaccess.
That's it.
See you next time.